Christian I want to ask you Thor love
and thunder I loved you as Gore thank
you almost to the point where I was like
I want to see Christian back in the MCU
again I'm just curious if you would take
on since Gore has such a distinct look
if you would take on another role if you
were approached for the MCU to come back
good story is a good story good
character you know good director of uh
you know if it's an interesting thing
and crucially if my kids are telling me
that I'm not allowed not to do it that's
what happened with Thor right yeah they
said no you
say no to that you're saying yes to that
and I went
now Harry I want to ask you because we
recently lost the great Robbie Coltrane
and I always hear the greatest things
about you know people who worked with
him when when I say that what's the
first thing that comes to your mind what
do you think about him well I was lucky
enough to do the first film with him and
there was a scene we did and I just
remember laughing my head off the entire
time as a 10 year old I just found him
completely Charming uh completely full
of life
and just wonderful
um and so when I heard about him passing
I was it was it was very sad very sad
indeed
um but I would always have those
memories of him as as when I was 10. so
um he was a big presence when he I
worked with him too when I was 14 I did
Henry V oh my God he was full stuff oh
and he would come barging in and he was
Bloody funny and I can't repeat almost
anything that he said on TV but yeah a
larger than life yeah wonderful man
oh I needed a discreetly infiltrate the
condenser what is this Blood symbols
rituals oh my Lord I love this pairing
I'm obsessed I also love the
relationship between your two characters
and it's a special one in the film and
I'm just curious how you were able to
find that Cadence together as actors
offset it's an easy thing with this
bloke because he's fantastic at what he
does he's in an enviable position where
he's incredibly experienced right but
for many people they might not be
familiar with all of his work and so I
want to be him because he'll be po to so
many people but impeccably so right it's
it's the most enjoyable thing and so
it's just an absolute pleasure real Joy
I learned so much from Harry he learned
nothing
that can't be true Harry totally true
what do you think what do you think
about that well it's it's not true but
um what I will say is when you work with
uh incredible actors
um they elevate you they elevate you to
their whatever you want to call it their
place their genius their whatever you
want to call it um they make you better
and that was my experience of making
this film was just being elevated by
these an amazing array of factors I love
it I would love to solve a murder with
Edgar Allan Poe if you could solve a
murder with any historical figure who
would you pick do you know who came into
my head straight away Jesus
I don't know why but I was like I want
to go on a detective Journey with Jesus
Jesus
um yeah just that was just
I'm gonna say Harry Kane because I feel
sorry for him right now
yeah I know but don't feel bad Harry
like he's brilliant yeah he is yeah yeah
yeah I grew up in Delaware and there was
a bar down the street called Deer Park
Tavern it's still there but there was a
a legend that Edgar Allan Poe stayed
there fell in the mud and then cursed
the building and now it's haunted by a
girl no oh wow that's great yeah we
spent a night there it's not a hotel
anymore it's a bar but it used to be a
hotel
pretty much
now Harry can you tell me about your
physical transformation I heard like you
know they shave your hairline back a
little bit you also opted not to do the
iconic mustache can you talk about that
yeah um so the hair was one of the early
decisions they kind of shaved it um this
hairline kept going back back just to
give them that very prominent forehead
which we all recognize as being very Poe
and the mustache was interesting because
obviously when you think of him you
think of having a Tash but the whole
point is we're trying to understand who
was the earlier version of Edgar Allan
Poe and and so he thought let's not have
a Tash let's let's kind of give us room
to invent who this person might be and
in the physicality was just sort of it
wasn't necessarily consciously thought
of it was just stuff that came from
wearing a costume and and building up um
the certain characteristics of what this
poem might be um I love it I I you know
despite the gothic error of the film you
know the murder mystery of it all I hear
there was a lot of levity on set some
giggling
um what what do we giggle about on set I
do tend to find that the more
serious a film is I've got kind of
gallows humor right yeah so I do start
giggling at the worst moments and you
have to get that out you have to kind of
expunge that you know a lot so just
silliness and what we do is silly I mean
you know we play dress-up for a living
right so it's intrinsically very silly
and open to lots of silliness as well
and um and yeah and so you know I'd say
lots of ridiculously distracting things
to Harry because he's too good he's too
good bloody good that's what it was do
you try to mess with him I would try to
throw him off his game so that I would
look better by comparison
um singing little songs in his ear right
before he starts going on and whatnot
and seeing if he can still keep a
straight face and he does he's very good
you know
um but I do I do uh I I it's risky for
me because you know it's called corpsing
right but and I do that once I start I
can't stop and it's to the point where
people are really annoyed with me and
the more annoyed they get the more funny
I find that as well and it's just a
never-ending downward Stars when you get
it
actually when it's a Friday night and
everyone's tired and wants to go home
for the weekend it's abysmal but yeah
did you say it's called Corps thing
I've never heard that
um the great Robert Duvall appears in
the film oh yeah fantastic making it a
sort of Newsies reunion 30 years later
did you two have a trip down memory lane
together absolutely we in between takes
they couldn't stop us singing all the
Newsies songs together I hope that's
true absolutely true and Harry knows the
more by heart as well and we would all
the three of us would do all of the
routines let's go let's get it thanks
[Music]